kind of the beginning when we have to
restore the soul of this country but we
saw coming out of Charlottesville that
hate and that venom that we saw and then
the president saying when asked about
the groups that met him as well as the
young woman when she was killed what did
he think about he said we're very fine
people in both groups
very fine people no no president city
president that's ever said something
like that and the only thing has
happened as it's gotten worse the way
there's an attempt to divide us divide
us in a way that in fact is totally
contrary to who we are we really are in
a fight to restore the soul of this
country we've led the world in the past
because not just that we had most
powerful nation in the world but it's
been the not the executive exercise of
our power it's been the power of our
example and around the rest of the world
we're losing that kind of influence in
the world and it's very damaging both at
home and abroad the second reason I am
running and I've said at the outset is I
want to restore the backbone of this
country the backbone in this country is
the middle class the middle class built
this country Wall Street did not blow
this country and the mid class made it
possible
made it possible working-class people to
make her way up the poor to have a road
up and with the middle class steps well
everybody does well the poor do well the
wealthy do well and the middle class is
the thing that the glue that holds us
together but it's falling apart right
now we're no longer the wealthiest
middle class in the world we're in a
situation where you have a significant
portion over 50% of them saying that
their children will never have a life
that they had my dad used to have an
expression he'd say you know Joe a jobs
about a lot more than a paycheck it's
about your dignity it's about respect
it's about your place in the community
how can you in fact have dignity how can
you in fact have this notion of being in
look your kidney on seven he's going to
be okay if you don't have adequate
health care you do when you turn you
look at a child and as a pre-existing
condition and there's nothing you can do
about it or when your child or someone
you love as terminal disease and come
like my son did it come along I can't
imagine what it would like watching him
and is coming home from Iraq whether
getting curable disease given months to
live different insurance company people
come in and say by the way your times up
suffer in peace the last four months
it's about being able to have an
education for your child that they that
you know they need and you know they
have an opportunity for that's why I
think we should be out there and we can
afford it tripling the amount of money
we spend on what's called title one
schools raising salaries for teachers
making sure making sure that we deal
really early on with all those crises we
know if we send kids to school at three
four and five years old they have
exponentially greater prospects of
succeeding every study has demonstrated
that we also know we need teachers my
wife is a full-time teacher taught all
during beam when we're in vice president
the fact of the matter is we're in a
situation now where there wuntch one for
every one child very psychologist in the
school system there are 1700 kids what
are we doing what are we doing we can
afford to change this if we just get rid
of some of this god-awful tax cut that
was passed the idea that we're in a
position that we have a trillion six
hundred billion dollars worth of worth
of loopholes law you can't possibly
justify four to five hundred billion of
that I can make sure that every single
solitary person in the country has
adequate health insurance build on
Obamacare make sure it has a public
option increase the prospect of while
we're in a lower drug price and you're
going to unless you ask me about it how
much time I have left
how much
fifteen seconds Oh to speak Oh y'all are
in real trouble baby that's a bad thing
to tell me I got more time to speak good
luck folks the idea that we can't gain
control and give people a fighting
chance is simply not correct there used
to be a basic bargain in America and
Republicans and Democrats agreed on it
we disagreed on the extent of it but we
agreed on beginning that after the end
of the Roosevelt administration and that
is if you contribute it to the
well-being of the company you work with
or the outfit you work with you got to
share the benefits and if it went well
you did well that's no longer the case
anymore we've adopted a position in
America that says the only people reward
in Title II rewards are stockholders
because there are the only job creators
they've adopted this notion that the
only people who very engaged in and able
to get the rewards that corporations
make are in fact the people who the
stockholders because there's a job
creators well-liked notice the folks
delivering the grain to the middle
they are job creators I noticed the
people who make the automobiles they
create jobs I notice the people who
build this country build this country
are ordinary were hard-working people
who've been given half a chance and
folks the idea that we don't reward work
as much as wealth is bizarre we're in a
situation where you have the top 1% in
fact making paying a lower tax rate than
you do because it's mostly capital gains
then more than a teacher a firefighter a
cop it's ridiculous we should be
rewarding work not just wealth we should
be raising the corporate tax cut so
folks this is always our capacity to do
this is all in our capacity we have so
much money so much in taxes tax breaks
for people who don't need them and by
the way the one thing how they don't
need them they're not bad people they
don't need another tax cut if you're
making more than a 10 million bucks man
I'm not your guy you know you don't need
a tax cut and you know it but
people need a tax cut are the people we
actually make sure we can provide for
free Community College we're in a
situation where we can put every single
solitary person who in fact is eligible
qualifies and those people have lost
their jobs and their 50s because of
automation go back to be retrained we
can do that all for about six billion
dollars a year eliminate one single
little thing it's called stepped-up
basis I didn't know what it was because
I used to be listed as the poorest man
in the Congress I didn't understand it
what happened was if you have a capital
gain you're about to have cash you then
you get hit by a truck god forbid you
leave it to your son or daughter they
pay no tax that cost the government 17
billion a year out of one trillion 600
billion eliminate that one tax that can
do it put every single qualified person
in Community College for free and or
trade school cutting in half the cost of
college there's so many opportunities we
have to change things in this country
folks in addition to that you know I
love the fact that there's no global
warming you all know that out here in
Iowa you know it doesn't exist I heard a
farmer today on the TV who was
Republican said well I don't think it's
caused by humans but I have a problem I
have a problem well there's a big
problem if we don't provide for people
being able to drink position where they
in fact to breathe clean air we deprive
them of their basic fundamental rights
first thing I would do as president
United States I've rejoined the Paris
climate Accord which I helped put
together and one other thing people
don't know about that Accord it calls
for what we negotiated it requires those
190 some nations to up the ante every
two years folks we are responsible for
15 percent of global warming the rest of
the world is run eighty five percent we
do everything perfectly and they don't
get on the stick that we're all still in
trouble so folks I know how to deal with
these world leaders
I know mostly every one of them I've
dealt with them I know how to get it
done bring them back
gather again because this is the
existential threat to the United States
to the world and it's real
and it's not it's not just 11 years we
got about 10 years before we lose the
opportunity to stop there Rosen it's
occurring now it's real and so folks we
can make but here's the deal you saw
what you did with wind I remember out
here early on at a State Fair 10 years
ago 12 years ago talking about wind and
how do you provide for energy from wind
well guess what a lot of people out here
anything is a good idea then you started
doing a created 10,000 new job didn't
cause any cancer as the president says
generated growth well folks we can
invest we will invest 40 billion dollars
forty four billion dollars in research
and development for new technologies
that deal with sequestering of carbon
your flowers out here can have an entire
new life they can be the first group of
America to actually get carbon free
environment that they generate and so
but we're in the process if we do this
will create 10 million new jobs and it's
real if we invest in research and
development and technologies that are
the technology of the future we should
become the net exporters of this
capability of technology we have a
potential to do that we underestimate
our capacity so so badly and ladies and
gentlemen go back to health care we can
control drug prices my proposal is and I
ran to the what they call the moonshot
dealing with cancer and something after
that set up the Biden cancer initiative
and then here's the point one of the
verge of solving so many chronic
diseases it's within our capacity to do
it but we have to actually go out and we
have to fund it for example value though
those who've been in the Defense
Department those have you been in the
military no there's not feel called
DARPA it's the thing that allows the
military to do advanced research and
everything from stealth technology the
internet all those other things and they
Dunnan and they've invested because
about the best minds in the world ended
deal with the problems of military faces
we should be doing the same thing with
health care we should set up the same
operation a Harper beaming health care
advanced research and development we put
that in guess what if we don't do
something about the disease of
Alzheimer's which in fact is every
single solitary bed in the United States
American Hospital will be filled with an
Alzheimer's patient within 20 years no
drug company is going to make that kind
of investment that it takes we should be
investing the billions of dollars we can
just like we did in the Defense
Department that obesity deal with with
all the chronic diseases that are out
there we have the capacity to break
through we can now do a million billion
calculations per second we are so far
advanced that we're just keeping our
head in the sand we should be investing
in that not investing in more tax cuts
for the very wealthy lastly I'd say the
third reason our enemies want to get to
your crescents is to unite the country
folks they told by some of my colleagues
that you can't unite the country that
Biden the one on one side they make well
by he's kind of been around too long the
other side is by just naive well I don't
know I've been around a long time you'd
think been here a long time you learn a
little something you know and the thing
I've learned is that the American people
after four years after three years
already of this guy have decided that a
lot of what he's talking about is hokum
look what happened this last election in
2018 around the country I went into over
24 states and over 69 candidates and I
went into those purple states in those
red states as well and in those states
we won back 41 seats beating Republicans
why we did it by the way not all
Republic
but here's the deal the fact of the
matter is they we ran on health care it
wasn't until they started taking away
health care everybody realized how
important it was that you're able to
cover pre-existing conditions twenty
million more people over a hundred
thousand hundred thousand people who in
fact were able to get coverage because
of pre-existing can
and so on but the proposal is we're able
to go out and make sure that everybody
is protected by building on Obamacare
restoring restoring the historic feel
that we did in addition to that adding a
Medicare like option to it so you can
buy into that if you wish to do it every
single band but you're able to keep if
you're like your employer based pop
policy you can keep that policy as long
as they keep the policy and so the folks
that matter is it cost a lot of money it
cost about seven hundred forty billion
dollars over ten years well guess what
it doesn't cost thirty three million
dollars thirty trillion dollars with the
other plans cost which are going to
raise middle-class taxes Bernie's honest
enough to tell you that they're going to
have to be a tax exactly withholding tax
on here I'm from from your paychecks
folks we can cover everybody and we can
do it in a way that allows people to
choice that they want if they don't they
don't like what they have they can buy
it immediately so folks look the terms
of unifying the country you know we
never lived up to it but America has
been in ideas the most unique idea in
all the world not a joke
there's not the only thing that can
defeat America's America there's no army
strong enough no dictator powerful
enough no ocean wide F that in fact can
overcome what we're able to do we can do
whenever we want to do if we remember we
can do it together
folks you know reason I did my last
announcement of Philadelphia was to make
a point that we are a nation that is
unique we hold these truths elf evident
the law of men and women are created
equal endowed by their creator we the
people learn a form of a perfect union
etc we've never fully lived up to that
but we've never abandoned it before
we've never walked away from it
Jefferson the Rowett didn't live up to
it he had slaves
we've never fully lived but every single
generation every generation has bent the
arc more toward inclusion every
generation and ladies and gentlemen
that's why were who we are we are
we are the most unique idea it's an idea
we cannot abandon and folks we are
better prepared to own the 21st century
than any nation in the world by a
longshot
well I got elected as a 29 year old kid
to the center that was labeled this
young idealist I was able this this guy
who in fact was optimistic the fact of
the matter is that more optimistic today
with one exception than I've ever been
if we get rid of Donald truth the path a
career path we have the most productive
workers in the world three times
productive as a matter of fact as
workers in Asia we're in a situation
where we have more great research
universities in the United States and
all the rest of combined and every major
change that's occurred in the last 20
years has come out of a research
university people think the federal
agent you you pay for them they belong
to you the American people thirdly we're
in a position where we have the most
agile venture capitalists were in a
position where we also have one of the
best educated public's in the world if
we in fact invest in them and so folks
look there isn't anybody there in any
country the world can compete with us if
we invest in our people if we invest in
them we are remember who we are
there's not a single thing we've been
unable to do it's time and this is my
concluding comment y'all it's time
remember who in God's name we are this
is the United States of America there's
nothing we've ever decided to do we've
been unable to do it period
that's not hyperbole we have never never
never failed when we're together
ladies you tell them it's time to get up
everybody knows who Donald Trump is even
as supporters humble he is
we got a lot of know who we are we
choose unity or division we choose
science over fiction we choose
other facts so folks if you're
interested join me I could use the help
because bust must defeat this president
to change the trajectory of this country
thank you all very very much
I guess I'd take questions don't let
anybody know I didn't use all my time I
have a great reputation of Oh going over
all the time yes sir question down here
and give you a biker
well I think maybe for it yes you can
buy me another way I already had one you
said can I buy you an ice cream and who
is my favorite historical figure I think
maybe my favorite historical figure is
maybe there's a couple philosophers that
I find that in fact understood about
human nature better than most people but
in terms of political figures I think
that may be my favorite political figure
would and it's a tough call but I would
have to say it's those presidents and
those people who gave America hope made
them believe in who they are and I'd
have to start off and you said not a
present I have to start off with
Jefferson even though he didn't live up
to it he's the guy that wrote that
incredible document and I'd have to say
that there a number of people who in
fact have moved in a direction to
provide us with the kind of hope and
expectation about what we can do my
favorite line from John Kennedy's speech
about going to the moon wasn't what most
people remember the one I remember the
most is when he said we're doing this
because we refused to postpone
I refuse to postpone any longer what we
can do in this country is time to get
the hell up and start to move that's
been
the lady said thank you for mentioning
Alzheimer's you know that it's already
costing Americans two hundred ninety
billion dollars a year right now what is
my plan my plan is to get gather up and
I've met with most of the leading
scientists in the country already my
plan is to set up a system whereby we
actually bought an invest the kind of
money which we're talking billions of
dollars in terms of the research that no
company no drug company wants to or
can't do because they can't take the
risk and I'm tired of being told that we
don't have a clear answer
we found clear answers we used to think
for example cancer was a single cell
that in fact presented resided in
different parts of the body we now know
there are two hundred four distinct
types of cancer that require different
kinds of therapies the same kind of
research has to take place dealing with
Alzheimer's and the reason is not just
to help people who have or in fact are
like to get Alzheimer's but it saves the
American it's a gigantic positive
investment because we pay for it
one way or another and we can change the
nature of how people it requires an
absolute dedication to say we are going
to invest we can do it it's going to
take billions of dollars to do it and we
can afford to do it we can't afford it
we can't afford not to do it yes men
question question is he said there's
been a number of my time 30 seconds the
courts he said it turned very very
strong to the right the point is I will
not appoint anyone to the court if you
notice that people when I I presided
over more Supreme Court hearings than
anyone ever has just because I was
chairman for such a long time that the
fact of the matter is the people I'll
put in the court of the people like a
woman who worked for me Elena Kagan the
people I put on the court or people that
we put on the court who in fact are the
folks who understand as a fundamental
thing those are your lawyers the
question is are their own enumerated
rights in the Constitution fancy way of
saying that unless you acknowledge that
there is a right of Travis in the
Constitution as most leading scholars
agree that in fact you will not be able
to protect a woman's right to choose you
will not be able to protect all the
things that we seem to care so much
about
I will not appoint anyone to the court
so does not share that basic philosophy
thank you I'll come and answer your
question okay
I you ship out loud answer any more I'm
going to get dragged off to steady
my grandpa would say until they left us
ah see Joey keep the faith my gravel you
know Joey's spread it go spread the fame
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what's different now is number two I
think we're going to win some sentences
number three you have a majority of the
members of the NRA understanding that we
should do something about this they
agree the majority members in the NRA
and the idea that what's happened lately
does not go to the core of who we are
violates no one Second Amendment rights
to say that you can't own certain weapon
not allowed on a bazooka you can't own a
flamethrower you can't own a lot those
who say the tree of liberty is watered
with the blood of patriots they making
the case you got to have enough
firepower to take on the government if
they come after you well you need a lot
more than an ak-47 or they are 15 the
point of the matter is they are for no
reason other than other than to kill
people any any any guy out there a woman
out there as one hunter tells me they
need a clip with 15 20 30 or 100 rounds
they shouldn't be hunting they're very
badiy you know so the point of the
matter is we can get it done and we can
get background checks done we can get it
done because the public is finally at
the point where they are sick of it it's
sick of it and I've got it done once
before and I get it done again
why have take a number of executive
actions we did in our administration
that relate to background checks and the
rest but here's unlike Trump I know
there's a Constitution I am not allowed
to just by Fiat decide that is pres the
United States I by executive action I'm
going to take action requires a co-equal
branch of government the Congress to
support it
that's requirement so there's a lot we
can do there's a lot we can change in
terms of background checks and gun show
loopholes and the rest but in terms of
dealing with a core issue of getting
assault weapons off the street limiting
and limiting the number of bullets that
can be in a single clip that requires
legislation as I said I'm the only guy
that did it nationally before with help
of Dianne Feinstein we also did the
background checks bill with in fact the
whole Brady bill
I was a leader on that we can do it
again the public gets it and get it now
I believe everything the president says
is going encourages white supremacy and
I'm not sure there's much of a
distinction as a matter of fact maybe
and in fact out there trying to in fact
curry the favor of white supremacist any
group so whether he is or is not a white
supremacist he encourages that
everything he does he speaks to that
he's afraid to take them on have you
noticed the one time he used the word
white supremacy he was was not was he
gonna talk about sleeping he was awful
sleepy the way he was he thought
[Music]
many headquarters open look people want
to be asked people want to be asked you
gotta have an organization way early on
you know the polls have me head by 10 or
12 points the next person but it's early
it's real early
I plan on be here to earn the vote of
Iowa president but they say he's doing
the right thing it's just gonna cause
them a little financial pain in the
meantime I think they're causing a lot
more little financial pain we gonna
cause a lot to go bankrupt I think it's
going to cause an awful lot of ancillary
industries like the issues that make
attractive they're gonna be real trouble
we're focusing on the wrong thing with
children
I am I playing on and I've argued that
we should be very tough with China China
is stealing our intellectual property
China is stealing industries from us and
unless we in fact are able to unite the
world in taking or in China they're
gonna set the link for the road they're
gonna be in the position where what
we're doing now is we're going about it
the wrong way China is a problem they're
a security problem they are a they're a
technology problem but they're investing
more money for example in research and
development we are because they're
stealing off a lot of our intellectual
property
when you first came to Iowa many repeat
candidates
well I think that first of all I think I
represent a change we need these issues
before some things that I had been
involved with whether it's supporting
the middle class whether it's dealing
with international relations I know all
these world leaders and I've
demonstrated I can command their respect
whether or not is dealing with issues
relating to the issues that allow us to
be single nation bringing people
together and so look and so far so good
I do it by being meet look no one's ever
including reporters cover me all the
time
no one's ever dad what I mean what I say
the problem is sometimes I say all that
I mean I think what's going on now is
people are looking for at least it or
not I'm at a problem they're looking for
authenticity they're looking for
honestly looking for someone who has the
new ideas about how to deal with these
things so one of the things I hope it
comes with my longevity in American
politics is the fact that I've been able
to I've been able to gain a little bit
of wisdom along the way and what needs
to be done it is clear to me what needs
to be done is totally within our
capacity to do it without in fact doing
anything other than making the country
better yesterday while you were speaking
in Burlington while the president is
traveling the country immigrations
Customs Enforcement was conducting these
raids at me process
Mississippi is that the right approach
does this interior enforcement what we
should be focused on number ones we
should focus on having the comprehensive
immigration plan that provides a pathway
to citizenship we are should be in fact
legalizing dreamers right now and we
shouldn't fact have an actual program
whereby you're able to find an avenue to
have your asylum in case her and this
idea of what walking away from dealing
with allowing people to have asylum
hearings in the United States is bizarre
it's that the best of who you are that's
not who we are as a country
ok folks when you go out there there's
no need to separate children from their
families you don't need to put people in
cages at the end of our administration
we found that when you say show up at
such-and-such a date they show up we
don't need to do this and by the way the
people if anybody should be deported and
maybe say again absurd ministration
heading well I tell you what issues we
did an awful lot of Chandra and what we
did with China first of all was we got
them to join the fires peace accord the
climate Accord we got them to change the
direction of the
here's the other thing we did when China
for example is you know I spent more
time with Xi Jinping or any elected
official up to that time any world
leader and I remember him asking me when
I went over just to meet with you and
his folks about what was not the air
identification zoos we set up in the
South China Sea and I said we're not
going to pay attention so what do you
expect us to do taking I don't know like
you should but I'll tell you what we're
going to fly right through it so we
slowed b-52s on through we're sending
our aircraft let's do it we're sending
our folks China is not China is not
going to make the rules of the game if
we in fact invest in our workers if we
invest in leading the world again
bringing the rest of the world together
to make sure that we can put enough
pressure on China there they're going to
write the rules over a wheel you make up
25 percent of the world's economy but we
need at the front end of the
administration we're losing 800,000 jobs
a month
everything landed on the President's
desk Ilocos the reason why they're the
longest belong is expansion ever is
because of a Barack Obama our
administration did and so but now at the
time to understand that China means that
they say there this this new belt and
Road Road is what they're doing they're
exporting for example pollution we're
exporting coal are exporting pollution
car for carbon producing energy we have
to compete
so what are we done with this guy we've
stepped back from the world we said
we're out we're not going to pay any
attention we've got to confront them
across the board in China's problems
compared to the ones we face they
they pale in comparison to the
opportunities we have xi jinping would
change places with the president's
problems in a heartbeat we're in a
situation where they don't have enough
water as god bless them
today's talking about spending close to
a trillion dollars to get water to their
population they have the highest rates
of cancer investor in the world in the
next ten years more people are going to
die of cancer in China because of
pollution than the rest of the world
combined they have an aging population
where they cannot they have no
replacement workers from themselves
east and west there what they're doing
with leaders on in the western part of
their country is shameful but we're what
are we doing we are instead of dealing
with their allies staying together
sticking with South Korea sticking with
Japan sticking with it we are walking
away we're walking away and when's the
last time you ever heard a president say
he has a love affair with a guy who's a
thug who ettus uncles brains blown out
sitting across the table and then there
was Sandy Hook so what exactly would be
different this time why are you the one
to change that
I met with every one of those kids down
to Florida in fact I understand people
know I know they know I understand I've
beaten them before and I think convinced
I can rally support to beat the we
should Day and legislative filibusters
that's what's needed I think we'd have
to make that call on the fly
ending the filibuster thing is a very
dangerous thing to do because it's been
used by compression for the whole you
know when you talk and you start off in
the filibuster because we should not be
supporting any of these subsets period
all right thank you guys